hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Game of Thrones episode 7 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet we got so many callbacks so
many awesome things happen in this
episode toss up between Liana Mormon or
the blackfish as to who won the episode
the blackfish is a total badass he's
right out of book for all this Jamie's
stuff that's happening is from his
chapters during a feast for crows he
gets sent to Riverrun to do exactly what
you were seeing on the show to get the
black fish out of Riverrun because it
belongs to the phrase now but he calls
complete [ __ ] the same way Lyanna
Mormont just calls [ __ ] on everyone
just northern queen of sass so sue top
10 WTF and I'll explain book changes as
we go along so here we go number 10 the
Hound is back in they have a pre-credit
sequence they barely ever do that so you
know something special when the episode
opens with a scene like this before the
credits so he actually ended up
dominating a large part of the episode
the whole episode was about the journey
that he's been on like trying to become
a pacifist trying to learn a new way of
life like I'm trying to leave behind
those terrible things that I've done to
the end of the episode when he realizes
that he can't leave it behind vengeance
will be swift and amazing to watch so
this isn't necessarily a book change
it's something that we expected to be
revealed during winds of winter we meet
this group of people through Brienne's
character during book 4 so all kinds of
book 4 stop happening all across the
episode but as you can see brands
nowhere to be found this was just a self
contained Hound storyline with what Ian
McShane called a little peace cult here
and he's kind of a combination of Septon
mayor bald in the elder brother in the
books he's kind of an amalgam of both of
those characters but this is essentially
the way it plays out in the books just
the Hound is trying to convalesce and
leave behind his wicked ways my number 9
is just ian mcshane being on fire for
the entire episode he said that when he
came on it was for a one-off role and
then we found out why at the end of the
episode but just the way he jokes with
the Hat just his clever turn to phrase
he just totally nails it how many men
did it take to cut you down one and it
was a woman speaking of women number 8
Marjorie's oscar-worthy performance with
the faith if she makes it out of this
okay the small council better give her a
Best Actress Award but if it wasn't
clear all of this that she's talking
about reading this whole performance
that she's putting on for the high
Sparrow complete [ __ ]
even pretending to not have carnal
desires anymore that was so great
Tommen's probably like how come she
won't have sex with me Sparrow sent
booty call but did anybody think that
the high Sparrow was being a little
creepy now I think that he was just
trying to do the nice like okay we need
an air so you have to have sex with him
in order for that to happen so can we
make that happen because that's the way
it's supposed to be but also the passage
that she was reading from the book
seemed kind of misogynist like it was
all about the proper way for a woman to
calm down angry situations angry men so
the high Sparrow is doing a more
insidious version of what the cows were
doing to Danny when she first ran into
them they were treating her just like
complete crap look this is what you're
supposed to be doing this is your place
in society of course we know how that
ended so don't you feel like Marjorie is
going to try and do the same thing to
this situation I don't know that she's
gonna burn the high Sparrow alive the
way Danny burned the cows alive but just
because the high Sparrow seems so pious
doesn't mean that he's not being a
terrible person in a really insidious
way and Danny Dave actually said
something interesting after the episode
about the old way versus the new way so
that's kind of what's happening in Game
of Thrones they were talking about
what's going on in the north between the
wildlings and the other northern Lords
like the wildlings are more willing to
accept the new way of things than the
northern Lords are so the same thing is
kind of happening in King's Landing and
you could probably imagine it's
happening in the faith too but getting
up into the north number seven Liana
Morman
total badass queen of sass so this is
the 10-year old Liana Morman named after
Lyanna Stark who in season five told
Stannis to go screw himself there's only
one true Lord of the North in his name
is Stark
but she's sassing the hell out of Sansa
and John so they bring in Davos who's
like the little girl whisperer and you
kind of cry thinking about how he was
with Shireen how sweet that was but he
gives it to her pretty straight tells
her about the Nike he should really be
called the night's king but I think the
show's just trying to simplify a little
bit so it's all good she gives him some
men but everybody else just is not
having it there was so much Robb Stark
trolling going on in the episode where
they go round to the other houses and
they're like yeah I rallied - Robb
Stark's banners when he called me I was
loyal but what happened when I needed
his help he was a total [ __ ] so not
only is the north super xenophobic
they're also kind of done without Stark
not that they hate John and Sansa is
just that they're trying to rebuild in
the wake of what happened during the war
of the five kings so I think when it
comes time to fight the war for the dawn
they'll be a little more willing to step
in when White Walkers are on their
doorstep but for now John and Sansa are
[ __ ] out of luck
they're like the bad news bear army
number six though is that initial talk
with the wildlings where Jon's trying to
win them over they go back and forth but
it's one one like the greatest moment
ever when one stands up and just says
snow and that's it it's all settled if
what one says you're cool then you're
cool so this is kind of in keeping with
their relationship in the books one one
has this respect for Jon Snow Jon Snow
tries to protect him when at the end of
book five he tries to save one one from
being stabbed by a bunch of the Nights
Watch brothers they're going to kill him
and then that's kind of like the straw
that broke the camel's back they mutiny
on him stabbed him and that's the last
we hear of Jon Snow
but that's book five we know that John
has already passed his book plot but I
feel like moment moments like this where
one one stands up for Jon and shows that
he has respect for him
it's just acknowledging that just kind
of like a wink to that in the books and
also what happened at hardhome because
all these wildlings totally saw what
John Snow did at hardhome number five
Theon and yara and old volantis we're
going to go to marine we're gonna make a
treaty with that queen to take back the
Iron Islands
so I just love the idea of team Daenerys
versus team you're on so I know I just
did a video last week talking about your
on book six stuff George are Martin read
aloud from book six in the damp air has
visions of Euron on the Iron Throne
foreshadowing something that may come to
pass so in the books you're on is a
really big antagonist but so far on the
show he just announced intent to go win
over Daenerys although the way he talks
about it he's going to make her submit
and we know what happens when men try to
subjugate Daenerys they usually wind up
being burned or eaten by dragons so
because it's going to take your on so
long to build those ships and they're
already there with their small force I
think that Theon and Yara will get there
first but remains to be seen what
they'll do when Yara tries to make a
treaty with her but I think she'll be
more receptive of Yara than she would be
of Euron but number for Sansa gets a
raven she doesn't look happy about it at
all so you can see the deteriorating
situation with their army and
Littlefinger
offer of men like he has a giant army at
his disposal let me help you but she is
one have anything to do with them but
now she's like god damn it and she
realizes she's going to have to accept
his help they will need the men of the
Bale if the Bad News Bears
are going to win the day but it was
really hard to pick which one I thought
was the craziest out of like the top
three to rank these so these are almost
all like a three-way tie for number one
WTF
but the hound charges back in after the
Brotherhood now those people that tried
to write up and extort them I actually
thought that they would be the brave
companions because they're the ones that
typically terrorize the Riverlands as
we've seen them before they've been
based out of Harrenhal Harrenhal is much
closer to the salt pans where the quiet
Isle is where the Hound is so that's why
I assume brave companions but the Hound
set Brotherhood said that they follow
the red God so whether or not we see
Thoros of Myr again this is the
Brotherhood which kind of sucks because
they weren't evil people in the books
but against times are getting tough
whatever I guess they needed a more
compelling reason for the Hound to pick
up that axe again and charge after them
but number two arya gets the [ __ ]
stabbed out of her by the wave sure
could use a Gendry right about now as
she's looked bleeding out walking
through the streets so because she
doesn't have access to Arya's face I'm
assuming that it's not over we'll see
some kind of resolution to this but how
many of you were hoping that as she was
stumbling through the streets she would
bump into someone they would turn around
and that person would be Gendry just to
make you feel a little bit better about
all this though George R Martin
confirmed that book Arya would meet book
Gendry again he didn't go into great
detail but they will meet again in the
books no idea of kendrys ever going to
be back on the TV show but we do have
two more seasons so there's always a
possibility but if you ever wondered if
she was going back to Westeros this
pretty much answer your question she's
going to try and get there as fast as
possible especially now that the waif is
after her but number one of course is
Jamie versus the blackfish blackfish
totally won this episode he's such a
badass in the books and they totally
captured it on-screen favorite
performance hands-down
just looking Jamie up and out just
completely destroying him you have no
honor
Kingslayer I'm disappointed in you the
look on Jamie's face here is priceless
it's like someone ripped his dick off
like he just doesn't know what to say
he's so crestfallen yeah I guess I am
pretty terrible so as you can imagine
there's a couple different ways
workers respond to stuff like that when
people call them out for [ __ ] so I'm
expecting Jamie to double down and he's
going to be confronted with brihat so
like there'll be a big choice for Jamie
to make is he going to be true to what
I'm going to call team Cersei like is he
going to be a true Lannister or is he
going to do the right thing and try and
help Brienne so if you ever want a Jaime
to have a redemptive arc now is the time
to start praying for him to make the
right decision because if there's
anything we've seen in the past he's
capable of making the right decision but
frequently does not so this is gonna go
one of two ways and I just I want to
believe that he's going to find a way to
help Brienne I'm a little more hopeful
when it comes to Jaime's character
Cersei on the other hand who I kind of
left out of the video a little bit is on
the way down as you can see she's by
herself all of her support system has
left her pretty much nobody in King's
Landing likes her and nobody in the red
keep for that matter
she has no allies she only has the
mountain in the queen of thorns is just
laughing at her she's like the only
pleasure I'm getting at all this is
knowing that nobody cares about you in
one of the most fun things about Cersei
in the books at least in book 4 is that
she slowly starts to go crazy there's
some really fun wildfire stuff that ends
up happening in the books that I won't
talk about in this video just in case
they save it for the show but remember
we had the brand vision of wildfire so
wildfire might come into play before the
end of the series again so just be
prepared for something to blow up in
your face but let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the episode and what was your more
favorite scene was it Liana Mormon or
was it the blackfish I'm gonna go ahead
and assume that most people's favorite
was the blackfish or even seeing the
Hound again really it's like a three-way
tie the Hound is back the blackfish is
so awesome and Lyanna Mormont was just
so hilarious but we're still in the
middle of Jamie book 4 stuff there were
a couple really funny book things that
they left out when he confronts Edmure
Tully and we'll have to remember to talk
about baby catapulting in the rains of
castamere next week there's some really
funny Jamie stuff that I'm hoping that
they do next week that involves ed
mirrors baby a catapult in the rains of
castamere but if you guys didn't know
there's a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll be doing a Q&A later this
week
couple more bonus videos if there's
anything special you guys want me to do
video about just let me know in the
comments but overall great episode where
not a lot of like crazy big things
happen just a couple
oh [ __ ] he's back moments along with
payoffs like lleana Morman why you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my breakdown of all of
brands visions and you can click here
for my episode 6 video from last week
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you